اخبروا العلم باجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم اصابه اربعه وعشرين شرطيا
واعتقال اكثر من 30 شخصا في مواجهات
بضواحي باريس بين الشرطه ومتظاهرين يحتجون
على مقتل شاب برصاص الشرطه الحكومه
الفرنسيه تعلن اعتقال الشرطي المتهم
بالقتل ومكروم يعلن التضامن مع عائله
الشاب القتيل
بعد ساعات من اعلان البرهان هدنه بمناسبه
اول ايام عيد الاضحى اطلاق نار متقطع
جنوبي ام درمان وطائره حربيه تحلق في
اجواء الخرطوم والايجاد تدعو لوقف فوري
للحرب وتطالب اطراف الازمه ببدء مفاوضات
لمعالجه اسبابها
الامم المتحده تصدر تقريرا مثيرا للجدل
وذلك بعد ادراج روسيا في قائمه الدول
الاكثر انتهاكا لحقوق الاطفال وعدم ادراج
اسرائيل في القائمه التي تضم 24 دوله رغم
انه اشار الى ان السلطات الاحتلال قتلت 42
طفلا فلسطينيا العمل ماضي
في يوم الحج الاكبر حجاج بيت الله الحرام
يرمون جمره العقبه الكبرى في مشعر من
ويؤدون طواف الافاضه قبل المبيت بمنى في
غضون ذلك يحتفل المسلمون حول العالم باول
ايام عيد الاضحى المبارك وينحرون الاضاحي
سنه ابيهم ابراهيم تقربا للحظ الى اللقاء